nous revenons maintenant à l'interview
de margaret thatcher une interview
qu'elle a donnée tout à l'heure à
christine ockrent à la veille de
l'ouverture du sommet franco-britannique
qui se tient demain à paris et quelques
jours avant le sommet européen de dublin
madame thatcher qui a donc abordé tour à
tour les relations franco britanniques
n'ont pas entendu les échéances
européennes mais aussi les foyers de
tension internationaux et la situation
sociale en grande bretagne où la ville
avait lutté avec mind juillet contre les
syndicats de mineurs au nom de la
modernisation d'un grève dure depuis
plus de neuf mois
est-ce que la modernisation et volets
sacrifices nous luttons pour avoir une
industrie du char longue efficace avec
des prix raisonnables pour fabriquer
beaucoup à l'expressivité et avoir de
l'électricité à des prix raisonnables
pendant consommateurs ce qui veut dire
que nous devons réduire les puits de
mine qui coûte trop cher et cela bien
entendu entraîne des problèmes mais des
problèmes analogues et existe dans
d'autres industries si vous ne pouvez
pas vendre le produit au prix auquel
jouve le produisent évidemment vous
devez réduire votre production et je
dois dire que le président mitterrand
coup presque de moitié les mines en
france donc nous avons des objectifs
très analogue dans ce domaine y est de
tchatche veille pourtant l église dans
l'est
dénoncer le désespoir d'une société où
les choses matérielles semble acquérir
une importance plus grande que les êtres
humains pour quelles raisons êtes vous
si la ferme sur vos pas la raison est
très simple nous tous devons gagner
notre vie en vendant soit des biens et
des services entre hypo un prix que les
autres sont disposés à payer et vie mort
si chaque industrie dit je veux une
subvention qui est ce qui va payer
financer la subvention la plupart des
industries des services devrait être en
mesure de se financer elles mêmes est
d'avoir un excédent cet excédent walesa
pour payer les services sociaux la
défense mais vous imaginez un état avec
des gens qui souhaitent avoir plus de
service qu'il n'ya de possibilité de
fournir des services et c'est le devoir
oui je dis bien le devoir de chaque
industrie d'être gérée avec profit et si
cela n'est pas le cas et bien parfois il
appartient au gouvernement de dire ou es
ce que vous avez un avenir si vous avez
un avenir nous vous aiderons pendant la
période difficile autrement il faut peu
un peu fermé ces industries en europe il
est inutile de verser de l'argent dans
les industries d'hyères et cela aux
dépens des industries de demain
kadhafi le colonel kadhafi à là et ont
appuyé très activement burgaud et les
syndicats milliers dans ce pays est ce
que vous iriez voir kadhafi pour lui
dire arrêtez de vous ingérer dans nos
affaires intérieures nous avons été très
pénalisés lorsque notre syndicat des
mineurs a été dit avoir accepté de
l'argent venant de la libye la libye a
utilisé son ambassade dans les villes à
londres pour perpétrer des meurtres donc
nous avons rompu les relations
diplomatiques et nous avons été très
mordant d'alizée de constater qu'une
syndicats très célèbre s'est rendu dans
un pays qui avait perpétré ce genre de
meurtre à partir de son ambassade
allons
martic négocie donc vous ne chercherait
pas à entamer des négociations avec le
colonel kadhafi des négociations sur soi
sur sa tendance à gérer dans vos
affaires intérieures le nom de je ne
négocierai avec le colonel kadio cia ce
propos nous avons fait connaître notre
union au syndicat des heures en nombre
de mineurs un feu sont extrêmement
choqués et je me souviens du moment où
le coeur a été assassiné dans la rue
dans le colonel kadhafi allant nombre de
personnes ont vu cela certains ont été
blessés
vous ne pouvez pas avoir de bons
rapports avec des pays qui se comporte
de cette façon
desagneaux pin sommes attaqués à un
sommet européen qui aura lieu à dublin
la semaine prochaine maintenant que vous
avez gagné votre combat en matière de
budget de la communauté que vous avez
récupéré beau fond est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de continuer à lutter
notamment dans le domaine de la
politique agricole la politique agricole
absorbe 70 % du budget de la communauté
je dirais que ce sont les autres
secteurs de l'économie qui peut-être ont
des plaintes à émettre à propos du fait
que l'agriculture absorbe 70 % et qui
peut être se plaignent du fait que nous
ne devrions pas gérer une politique qui
produit des montagnes de produits
alimentaires que nous ne pouvons pas
pour sommer qui coûte vous en magazines
et c'est insensé
nous on travaille tous je souhaite que
cela soit géré efficacement efficacement
pour l'industrie agricole une industrie
efficace ne produit pas des montagnes de
beurre de boeuf de poudre de lait c'est
absolument insensé et ça n'est vrai
juste pour ceux qui doivent fournir les
fonds une ossature nick drake vers
surnom en france comme ailleurs lady la
dame de ces la dame de fer tu n'es mais
est ce que c'est une image qui vous
plaisent à x ou bien est ce que c'est
quelque chose au fond qui consolide
voter tout président tout premier
ministre doit être très ferme doit
savoir ce qu'il veut et la façon dont je
gère ma politique m'amène à dire ce que
je pense à lutter pour que ce truc pour
ce que je crois être juste je ne peux
pas changer ma façon d'être je ne
souhaite un échange et du score je crois
que c'est un britannique et je pense que
cela a juste à la communauté chacun
d'entre nous en apportons notre style
nous ne voulons pas être des copies
conformes les uns les autres nous
voulons être complémentaires je ne pense
pas que cela laisse mon image oui je
suis très ferme sur certains domaines
pourquoi parce que je crois en certaines
choses
est-ce que c'est pas normal de la part
d'un politicien et un grand nombre de
ces politiciens se sont avérées avoir
raison finalement